>> That is exactly the right question to ask. It's fun
to spend all day finding the VC dimension in various hypothesis
classes. But that is not why we are here. The reason
we're, why we're here is to use that insight about VC dimension
to connect it up with sample complexity. And so here is
the equation that you get. When you connect these things up.
It turns out that if you have a sample set the,
the size of your trading data, is at least as big as
this lovely expression here. Then that will be sufficient
to get epsilon error, or less, with probability 1
minus delta. And so, the form of this looks
a lot like how things looked in the finite
case. But, in fact it's a little bit weirder.
So 1 over epsilon times quantity eight times the
VC dimension of H. So that's where this quantity
is coming into play. So the VC dimension gets bigger,
we're going to need more data. Times the log base 2
of 13 over epsilon. Sure. Plus 4 times the log
base 2 of 2 over delta. So, again, this log
of, of something like 1 over delta to the inverse
of delta, was in the other bound, as well, that's
capturing how certain we need to be that, that things
are going to work. And again, as, as delta gets
small, the failure probability gets small. This quantity gets bigger.
And the num, and the size of sample needs to be bigger. But, but this is
the cool thing. That the VC invention is
coming in here in this nice, fairly linear way.
>> So it sort of plays the same role as
the natural log of the size of the hypothesis space.
>> Yes, that's exactly right! And in fact,
things, things actually map out pretty similarly in the
finite case and the infinite case. That there's an
additive term having to do with the failure probability.
There's a, you know, one over epsilon in the front of it and then
this quantity here, having to do with
the hypothesis space, is either the size of
the hypothesis space or the dimension of it, depending. Well the size here is
logged and the VC dimension is not, so that's a little bit of a difference.
>> Mm.
>> But but there's a good reason for that as it turns out.
>> There is?
>> Yes, indeed. So why we, why don't we take
a moment and look to see what is the VC
dimension of a finite hypothesis class? The VC dimension
concept doesn't require that it's continuous. It's just that
when it's continuous, the VC dimension is required. So
that maybe that's a useful exercise. Let's do that.